okay um
welcome everyone I hope everyone can
hear me
um yeah my name is venkat guruswamy and
I'm a senior scientist here at the
Simons Institute and uh it's my great
pleasure to welcome you all to The
Institute and in particular to this
week's workshop and I guess it doesn't
need much introduction but the Simon's
Institute is the leading international
venue for collaborative research in
theory of computing and related fields
it was established in 2012 by generous
Grant from the Simons Foundation who
continue to support us very generously
and every semester The Institute builds
brings together world's leading
researchers in various Fields related to
Theory as well as the next generation of
outstanding young scholars and this is
the 10th year of programs at Simons and
these programs have together really
pushed the frontiers of TCS in so many
directions they've made progress on
long-standing challenges of the field
and also opened up new directions of
inquiry and I think this week's Workshop
is a illustration of the lateral theme
and on top of these thematic semester
programs which run through the semester
The Institute also hosts various
Outreach activities to enhance and
broaden the appreciation of an
understanding of TCS and it also hosts
workshops on timely topics of
significant importance and promise and
again this week's Workshop fits that
theme perfectly and so this week we are
pleased to host uh one such workshop on
multi-group fairness and the validity of
statistical judgment and I would like to
take a moment to thank the organizers of
the workshop for their work uh in
putting together a great uh program so
they are uh Alexandra
Anika
um
Moritz Michael and Omar
I think most not all of them are here
ready so thank you
to give more details about the workshop
itself but before I hand it over to him
just a few logistics for the coming week
so food is provided before the first
talk and in the breaks just outside
where we were now and for lunch you're
on your own but there are many options
uh nearby walking distance and we ask
that you please uh leave any food and
drinks including coffee uh outside the
auditorium helps us keep the space clean
and if you need to store your things
during the day there are lockers on the
back end of the building
um you can use that and they're very
easy to use and our videographer omia
will be here throughout to help speakers
get set up if there are any issues and I
believe there is also a zoom link for
this workshop and it's hybrid so for
people in the room raise your hand to
ask questions others I guess hopefully
assistant Shares are monitoring and we
will find it yeah yeah they will be
monitoring and Fielding questions and I
finally a special thanks to our events
team Ashley Hassan and Elizabeth Ewan
for managing all the logistics for this
week's event takes a lot of effort to
put together an event and particularly
events which are not part of the
semester the one-off events like this so
a big thanks to them so
and uh
thank you welcome everybody
I know that organizers should only think
that the end because you need to think
based on the actual
to see if it was worth it but hopefully
it will and there are two Simon Simon
Foundation is involved in this in two
ways first through our gracious and
wonderful host the fight at the Simon's
Institute and also through the Simon's
collaboration on the theory of
algorithmic fairness which is organizing
and the event and which
supported a lot of the research we're
going to talk about
and in four sentences I think we'll see
the premise of this Workshop is the
following about five years ago and
Notions of multi-group fairness have
been introduced in the context of fail
working fairness and various
a continuous struggle to understand
Notions of fairness we want we'll talk a
little bit about fairness but we'll talk
about other connections mostly this week
and because at the beginning we already
knew some connections through algorithms
that we adopted from machine learning
statistics game theory that were very
useful and made these Notions achievable
but over the last five years there's
been a growing understanding of a lot of
connections
um both to all of these areas and to
indistinguishability complexity Theory
and we'll talk a lot about these
connections and are the growing
understanding that we have hopefully
first to get all of us into their same
position and perhaps to foster a new
research and to focus new research on
whatever challenges we find are exciting
and in terms of the organization of the
week today will be kind of um
like a mini boot camp
and and then Tuesday and Wednesday will
be we'll talk about learning statistics
Thursday we'll have a lot of
complexity Theory and distinguishability
and Friday will look Beyond but of
course there are other reasons for
putting talks in different times so it
won't completely follow this but this is
the general rule and with that I want to
introduce
and Michael was going to
take over and talk about
multi-calibration outcoming
distinguishability in the next two slots
thank you
[Applause]
all right
um can everyone hear me I'll project
more
great
um so
uh as Omar said I'm going to speak about
this site two ideas uh multi-calibration
and outcoming distinguishability
um really sort of there are two parts of
this talk I planned one really long talk
so we'll break whenever it feels natural
um or when the time is up
um and so yeah for today I'm going to
start with overviewing uh
multi-calibration as a notion of
algorithmic fairness and really try to
dive into some of the technical details
that I don't often talk about in sort of
uh
the slide talks okay so I'm gonna go
through proofs I'm going to go through
sort of technical details
um so that hopefully uh we're all on the
same page
um and then in the second half I'll talk
about this idea of outcoming
distinguishability and how it's related
to multi-calibration how it's related to
some other Notions really the idea is to
set up uh the rest of the workshop
um where a lot of I think a lot of the
talks not all of the talks but a lot of
the talks down the road are going to be
using these ideas so
um please if things are unclear uh
especially at a technical level pause me
and interrupt me and uh questions I'd
rather get through you know 70 that I
need to get through and have everybody
understand it then get through
everything
okay
okay good so uh I think most of us are
probably on the same page about this if
you're at this Workshop but uh to begin
uh I wanted to motivate that algorithms
are everywhere we look these days
um and more and more uh they're
increasingly implicated in making
consequential predictions about people
okay ml algorithms are driving our cars
they're running advertising uh
marketplaces even making medical
predictions right and I like all of
these examples because they're
situations where historically human
decision makers have been highly
regulated to ensure for some kind of
responsibility or fairness right
um if you want to drive a car or you
want to practice medicine you need to go
get a license
and uh federal laws protect individuals
from discrimination in advertising okay
so as we move more and more of our
decision-making capacity from Human
decision makers to computational
decision makers through algorithms and
machine learning we need to start to
reason about what it means for these
algorithms to be fair what it means for
them to be responsible and try to come
up with uh satisfactory answers to this
question
okay
so uh rather than trying to address
questions of fairness on an algorithm by
algorithm and situation by situation
basis the program that we're talking
about today really uh tries to take a
more foundational approach stepping back
and and and formalized identifying
General concerns General patterns of
concerns like fairness in prediction
systems and then formalizing these
concerns into concrete definitions in
the language of computer science math
and statistics right and and really the
the hope is that these definitions will
clarify what we can and cannot achieve
uh using ml prediction systems
um and a huge emphasis will be on making
sure that we get the definitions right
and so in this in this line of work
we're really inspired by the success
stories of cryptography where subtle
human Notions like secrecy and privacy
have been formulated into uh concrete
mathematical definitions that not only
come with a beautiful Theory but also
underlie the the technical Tools in your
browsers today
okay so so that's sort of the the
backdrop
um as I said I'm gonna be introducing
some Concepts uh and sort of they'll lay
out the overview for today's talk
um we'll start with multi-calibration as
a notion of fairness and prediction that
gives A New computational Perspective
um
yeah so so
um I think the truth is that when we
when we talk about fairness we're going
to I'm probably this is the last time
I'm going to say fairness in the talk
I'm gonna give you a concrete definition
you're gonna talk about a specific
concern of a type of unfairness you
might anticipate
um and how that arises due to
miscalibration and then we'll talk about
multi-calibration as a solution concept
for
um to address that concern
um as we'll see I think throughout the
rest of the talk or throughout the rest
of the workshop there are other fairness
concerns that you might address using
the same tools but but really sort of
the I'm going to remove these quotations
marks pretty soon
great question
so so we'll talk about multi-calibration
and then outcome of solution
ability okay and so for
multi-calibration I want to give you
sort of a a high level idea of where
we're going I'm going to start with
preliminaries and motivation and sort of
technical
um background
um then I'm going to give you the
definitions and we're going to spend a
lot of time thinking about these
definitions and really uh digging into
them
um and then finally uh in the
multi-calibration section I'm going to
talk about an algorithm for learning
multi-calibrated predictors
this is sort of the the
goal
good so
um
good so while the concern for fairness
in systems out there these days is very
widespread for today's talk I want to
focus on algorithms that make
predictions about people okay so a good
example to have in the back of your mind
I think is that of medical risk
prediction okay where we're trying to
develop a predictor an algorithm that
takes in an individual patient's data
right somebody comes to the clinic you
put in their data you run it through
this algorithm this predictor and it's
going to spit out some predicted
probability of a certain Health outcome
say the the probability that they'll
have a heart attack in the next five
years
right
um okay and a bit more uh formally we're
gonna think about uh denoting
individuals as X
um these would X could represent an
individual patient's health records well
think about outcomes as why
um for today's talk uh we'll think about
why as being binary living in zero one
you could generalize this but again it's
an indicator of whether they had a heart
attack or not
um good and so then the the name of the
game in supervised learning is given a
bunch of individual outcome pairs right
given this training data from historical
examples train or find learn a predictor
P that maps in new individuals X into
the range zero one that will represent
some sort of probability of the health
outcome for that individual
great okay hopefully no questions yet uh
even more formally
um we're gonna think we're gonna work in
this what some called sometimes called
the agnostic path model okay where we're
given where we're given sample access to
a fixed unknown distribution that will
denote D start on X Y pairs
um importantly the agnostic here means
that we're making no assumption about
the the mapping from X's to y's right
we're we're not going to assume that
this comes from some simple class it
could be arbitrarily complex
okay and in particular our goal will be
to learn some estimate of individual
probabilities to learn a predictor that
given an X spits out a probability
um the Target that we'll have in mind is
this Bayes optimal predictor okay we'll
denote this as P star it represents the
true probability of the outcome being
one given X
given an individual X okay and and again
because of this agnostic assumption
we're going to make no assumptions about
the complexity of P star P star could be
uh computationally intractable it could
be even statistically impossible to
learn
okay and so so given that impossibility
given that hardness we're going to think
about what are meaningful solution
Concepts to recover meaningful
uh predictions and probabilities
okay that that's sort of the the
technical setup
any questions at this point
um feel free to interrupt me and jump
back if things are still unclear in the
in the future okay so so let's let's
jump into this idea of fairness Okay I
lied I'm going to use fairness uh a few
more times but so we're gonna talk about
um a concern of fairness due to uh
miscalibrated predictions okay
um and so here I'm gonna start with a
cartoon that's based on a real study but
it is in this cartoon
um I'm plotting the predicted
probability versus the actual
probability okay so so the these curves
here rep each point on the curve maybe
represents an individual person where uh
they have an actual probability and
we're looking at what the algorithm
spits out as their predicted probability
okay
um and so the the concern that we have
here
is that these predictions might be
miscalibrated okay uh I'll get into the
technical definition of calibration but
at a high level miscalibrated
predictions mean that that across
different groups the same predicted
probability means something different
okay so for instance in this pup in this
cartoon we have an orange population and
a blue population and the the
predictions mean something different in
the different populations okay what
what's the consequence of this
miscalibration the consequence is some
sort of disparate impact where the the
quality of care and the the the nature
of the predictions varies across these
different groups right so if we set a
fixed threshold on the predicted
probability in effect
we're setting two different group
specific thresholds on the actual
probability okay
um
and and so far from hypothetical this
cartoon is based on an empirical study
it looked at existing medical risk
predictors that are out there being used
in hospitals today that exhibit this
kind of miscalibration okay and what's
the consequence of that the what they
argued is that in order to qualify for
Advanced Care okay right this this uh
predictor maybe is used for triage and
so the the result that was shown is that
in order to qualify for Advanced Care
black patients had to be considerably
sicker than their corresponding white
patients right so in this case the black
patients would correspond to the blue
curve
um and so there the actual threshold
that needed to qualify for Advanced Care
was much higher you had to be much risk
is there we were the question about the
do you get access to the P Stars okay so
the question was about whether we get
access to feed star and the answer is no
we'll only assume P star is really in
our heads so imagine it as there being
some joint Distribution on X Y but we
only ever get access to X Y pairs yes do
we have any speculation
in this case yeah so so they they um in
this study they speculate that actually
it one of the reasons was a faulty
Target or a faulty proxy so what they
they indicted is that the algorithms
were originally trained on predicting
cost of care rather than on this
application
so so there's a number of different
reasons why this kind of thing might
occur that was what they
um indicted yeah the follow-up asked if
you don't see p star then how of you
talk about this graphic generator yeah
that's a great question so so again this
this cartoon is very much a cartoon in
our heads
um right we it's actually pretty
difficult to generate these actual
probabilities what does that mean
um you know in this study they did uh
they took some care to to try their best
to reconstruct these actual
probabilities
but uh but the concern still stands even
if even if
wouldn't you be able to accept he said
like
I mean good so in some cases the group
indicator yeah and did nothing sort of
data that means
that's right so so for we'll probably be
able to get a good estimate of the
probability within a group but given you
know your covariance exactly the
covaries defining frauka
um your internet history everything uh
all of the information that I could
observe about you I only ever get to see
your outcome once
um it's unlikely that I'm gonna see
um your your covariance that many times
that I could get an accurate estimate of
the truth that's that's the setting
we're living
as the actual probability given the
specific uh predictive probability right
not the actual probability
um
yeah I I understand I can't measure it
but in my head yeah
um
I'm I'm not sure so is it should I I
mean even every duck there yeah the
actual probability of being one
condition and having that predictive the
probability on your model or is it
should interpret it as a scatter plot of
the actual probability of giving one for
a particular individual or a
particularly like the latter no like a
scatter plot so in that case why is it a
function why is it not alive I mean
that's what I'm trying like it wouldn't
be you know oh yeah so I just did that
to um
so that I can say that the it could it
could not it could be like the cloud but
yeah yeah it's a it's yeah
it's meant as a very gross encouragement
um
yeah so that's a good question so let me
push forward about sort of what what we
would assume that we know about fees
um groups about the individuals and and
how we might uh try to address this
concern right so so
um
I said that the concern was given by
miscalibrated predictions a natural uh
solution then should be to try to
calibrate these predictions okay and in
particular we're going to need to think
about calibrating these predictions
across the groups of Interest so I will
assume that somehow these groups are
encoded in the features that we have
access to
um okay so what what what is calibration
calibration
um is a technical notion that is defined
by this conditional expectation
that's the first one
question
of the particular individual but this is
the first one right Mississippi
so so again I refuse it with the blue
line is and whether this is supposed to
capture them
no no the the so the the orange curve
and the blue curve are meant to
represent different indiv different
populations so don't understand okay
okay but what is the what's the x-axis
is the x-axis
I'm going back to my question because
it's different than what it says here
should the x-axis be the probability of
an individual or this should the x-axis
be so cute X for an individual or should
xxxtentacion a particular predictive
regarded
if you had
uh this is this is a new definition
that's not the same thing though that's
very those things are very different
right right yeah so but the x-axis you
should think of not as what you have
here I this is a new definition
x-axis is p star and plotting P star
versus P of x
is that clear like uh it's a cartoon
we're gonna push forward but um but I
hope it's clear that I'm plotting the
Bayes optimal probabilities on on the
x-axis versus the output of our
algorithm whatever it is
for now it's PMX
so so if at our groups here s
corresponded to the orange population in
the blue population then these
predictions would not satisfy this
definition it would not be calibrated so
calibration would sort of
uh they you know there there's a a bunch
of ways you could satisfy it but but at
very least it means that amongst the
individuals who are getting the same
predicted value you can't have different
actual average values
I guess the point is that like so for
the graph
for this graph television is not
satisfied but in television episode
that's correct that's correct
so good
right and so that's what we're going to
go through now so that the calibration
is trying to get that some idea it's
it's it's a good idea it's it's a it's a
maybe uh the first thing you would think
of okay so what what is this notion of
calibration calibration says that
predictions mean what they say okay so
that is when I look at the individuals
for whom I give out a value of v a
prediction of V2
then the expectation in this group is
actually roughly V
so that is uh amongst the individuals
where I say that
um there's a 20 chance of a heart attack
about 20 percent of them will actually
have a heart attack
um questions that we need to ask now
though are are there's a few key
questions first which groups should be
we be reasoning about right so so maybe
we did a very good job we you know
observe these orange and blue population
and recalibrate come came up with new
predictors and tried to match them up
this would be sort of an ideal situation
but in doing so maybe then we discover a
new population that we hadn't considered
okay
um then maybe we have to calibrate over
that group and maybe uh if we think
about groups defined by intersections of
attributes
um
you know then then it introduces even
more groups okay how do we reason about
calibration then
um and so the bigger issue though for
for why what the issue with calibration
is is that
um calibration allows a certain kind of
uh what I call algorithmic stereotyping
okay it allows you to treat a group
um as a monolith and ignore variation
within this group okay in particular
um so the result of this is that the
quality of the predictions can vary
significantly across significant groups
even under calibration okay so maybe in
this orange population we're matching
you know we we get a pretty good slope
one line
um
but in this blue population
you see that we we're giving out the
same prediction in everyone
um how can that be the case if we're
insisting on calibration well I said
that calibration needs uh calibrated
predictors need to mean what they say
but they don't need to say very much
okay in particular
it's possible to give out a fixed value
that is the mean of the distribution the
mean of the outcome the expected outcome
to everyone in the group
and satisfy calibration right because
then this conditioning on my prediction
doesn't do anything it just says look at
everybody in that group
and and indeed then the expectation of
the outcome is correct
okay so so this is a serious issue this
is a much more serious issue than like
um
whether you know we're lining up the
curves uh appropriately calibration on
its own is very weak it allows you to do
things where you just completely
Overlook the very the true variation in
P star in an entire group
okay
good and so in particular
um
while these predictions
might be uh calibrated on uh the blue
group as a whole there's certainly not
calibrated on important subgroups within
this group right in particular if we
were able to identify these higher risk
blue
uh patients then it somehow Witnesses
the fact that that on this subgroup the
predictions are no longer calibrated
okay and so so ideally ideally then what
we would push for is to be calibrated on
every group right if we were able to be
calibrated over every different subgroup
then we would effectively have to be
calibrated on individuals which would
mean that uh
we would basically learn P star we would
have to give out a fixed sort of slope
one line on this curve and and using a
fixed threshold on the predicted
probability would really correspond to a
fixed threshold on the actual problem
okay that would be uh the ideal the
question is what is a meaningful notion
of every group right pretty quickly when
we start to say things like this it
becomes very obvious that like
statistically this is not possible from
a small sample of data you just can't
learn something that is calibrated over
every group we said that P star is
likely inaccessible so we can't hope to
do this
but
we're going to try to push forward and
this is the motivation behind
multi-calibration
okay so so here's here's the high level
idea of multi-calibration the guiding
principle says that you want to protect
not every group but every identifiable
group okay
um that is to say that we want to
protect every group that we can hope to
identify given the data and
computational resources available to us
um and and this notion really provides a
qualitatively different notion than sort
of Standard Group calibration where
we're forcing through this notion we're
forcing the predictor to learn within
protected populations not just
marginally over the population as a
whole
okay
um the way we formalize this and we're
going to spend you know the next 10 15
minutes going through this is through a
collection of subpopulations okay so at
a high level we say for a collection of
subpopulation C the predictor is C
multi-calibrated if its predictions
appear calibrated over every subgroup
in this collection of sub-populations
okay
um and so really ideally The Collection
C should identify meaningful and
important subgroups
um that may overlap with one another may
be defined through intersections of
different features we want to think
about this collection as being a very
rich collection of subgroups and we'll
go through sort of the extremes of that
definition next yeah
you should think of C is like fix
beforehand or something that's learned
in the process yeah so c will throughout
we're going to think of C as being fixed
um concretely you might we'll see sort
of concretely what you might think of
fixing it to be
there's a few conditions
okay so so let's just sort of map out
where we are in terms of like we wrote
down a definition calibration over every
subgroup in some collection of subgroups
what what does this give us uh
technically
um and the point is that the collection
of sub populations that we choose really
uh determines qualitatively like what
what the strength and efficiency of the
guarantee will be okay on sort of one
extreme
if we set if we take this collection to
be let's say o of one protected groups
then we're going to recover this notion
of group calibration right
um that this um this notion is efficient
we can efficiently calibrate but as we
saw it it provides very weak protections
there's ways to treat groups completely
as a monolith not capture any of the
variation within the population
um even though the these groups are
supposedly protected by calibration that
so that's sort of that the one extreme
um of
a group notion of fairness On The Other
Extreme we can imagine sort of defining
an individual notion of individual
fairness or individual calibration
um this is sort of in Allah
um fairness through awareness but sort
of at the extreme you can imagine
defining a collection of subpopulations
based on single prints right every
single individual is a set and I want to
be calibrated on those individuals of
course this this is a ridiculous notion
to propose if you're hoping to learn
this thing from data but
um the point is that it recovers P star
and one can think about
um defining some Metric version of this
right so so
um if you're familiar with individual
fairness if you're not familiar with
individual fairness the point is that at
the extreme if we Define c to be
expressive enough then we do have to
recover the base optimal probabilities
okay so what that says is that at the
extreme it's a very powerful notion
albeit inefficient
okay and so the real question that we're
going to ask here is whether there's
something in between where we could hope
to choose a set a collection C
set system C that will give us a
powerful guarantee but also allow us to
get efficient Solutions
okay
um any questions at this point
okay I'm going to push forward then
um
so again the the perspective is that
we're we're gonna try to protect every
group that we can reason about okay what
what what does that mean okay I I need
to Define some minimal conditions
um
to even begin to talk about what it me
you know we need some minimal conditions
on what it means to to even identify a
group or even specify a group okay or
specify a collection of groups
um and I'm going to be informal about
these minimal conditions initially but
as we'll see you know towards the end of
this portion of the lecture there will
be like concrete bullet points of what
these Notions mean okay before doing
that a key correspondence that sort of
is the key uh to understanding a lot of
the papers in this area and sort of
um I think a major confusion in how we
talk about this but shouldn't be it's
it's I'm here to convince you that it's
not confusing is this correspondence
between subpopulations and Boolean
functions
okay
throughout I'm going to use to I'm going
to represent a subset s a subset of the
Universe X as a Boolean function
okay this Boolean function is just the
indicator function of set membership
it's just evaluating set membership and
and really this is a a correspondence in
the other direction too if I give you a
Boolean function it defines a
subpopulation
any questions about that
somebody wanted to volunteer to repeat
that back to me so that we're all on the
same page
yes thanks uh you can represent a
sub-population by the indicator function
of of that set so any any Boolean
function will induce a subpopulation
where
ones indicate membership in the
population and vice versa any
subpopulation of juices great great
exactly and I'm going to be thinking
about
um one one thing that I don't have on
the slide here but that again hope is
obvious is that rather than conditioning
onset membership I can also multiply by
this Boolean function okay so so and
we'll lose some some you know factors in
terms of how large this subpopulation is
but really conditioning on set
membership I want you to think about as
multiplying by a Boolean function yes so
with this definition you can sort of now
get fuzzy definitions pretty easily will
you be taking that approach absolutely
yeah so so rather than thinking about
this as a Boolean function everything
that I will say throughout this entire
talk it also apply to a bounded
bounded functions even even uh with
negative approach yes uh like thinking
back to the previous slide you said like
the extremes are of one the size of
reflection and there's some nutrition
you have like what's the bills
um we'll see it's actually not so much
about the cardinality it's more about
the complexity of the collection
um good so here here's sort of the key
fuzzy definition at this point that I'm
going to write down
um but that will become concrete by the
end of the lecture so I'm going to say
that a class of functions a class of
Boolean functions a class of
subpopulations using this term
interchangeably is computationally
identifiable okay is identifiable if it
satisfies two conditions first of all is
some sort of efficient efficiency
condition computability condition that
every
um function in my class has some bounded
complexity representation okay has small
circuits can be computed by a linear
function or a small decision tree
okay
some sort of complexity bound the second
condition is a little fuzzier to state
right now but it's an auditability
condition
it says that given a bunch of data
appropriate data I can find
within uh sort of the population if
there are any
um popular if there are any
subpopulations in my collection
on which my predictions are
miscalibrated
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna use that uh
auditing condition as a primitive to
start and we'll show how to make it
concrete
be technical
computational problem
okay so so this is really the key
um
Framing and it leads us to a general
recipe for coming up with multi-group
fairness definitions okay
so
can you give an example where
some cable but not audible or the other
way around so
um
not exactly because it it's sort of if
it's uh got a well okay let me just say
that if it's computable
um here here's a trivial auditor
suppose that your classic functions is
is discrete and finite and just iterate
through each collection and and run some
statistical tests
so so there is pretty much always a a uh
an inefficient auditor and sort of what
we're really after is sort of for an
efficient auditor and we'll Define
exactly what that means later on
circuits
circuits are computable but
and I can imagine
because the iterating over them would
take it exponential how
but you know if you have a concrete
bound on the size of the circuit then in
principle one could just iterate so and
notability are you only understand this
computational concern yeah since your
only concern or are you also concerned
about this list but like if we think of
for example all singletones yep and the
problem there is I don't it's not really
computation I mean yeah it's a
computable class right I mean the whole
Singleton yes but the problem there is
with disability is a statistical
problems with it exactly so I mean are
you worried here where this is okay
statistical and computational it needs
to be feasible to audit for the the
parent solution and it says from data
does that mean a finite data set or yeah
I'm sorry uh hey I can you know find an
example whatever you get you get
um but yeah
Russell
um You probably you mentioned this kind
of implicitly before but you're going to
be normalizing by the probability of
getting elements from that set by
multiplying by this characteristic
function yes so so this issue about not
having enough statistical
uh
you know having noted having enough
statistics to make meaningful checks for
the function is probably going to be
handled by this normalization that's
right so so Russell's point is that
um basically the statistical aspects
will be wrapped up into some sort of
approximation and sort of um if you're
if your sets are so small that it's
statistically hard to audit for them
then either you need to take your error
parameter so small that you can detect
them which will require a lot of data or
you need to give up on the smallest of
populations
that'll be the next definition
right
yeah we'll see
we're pushing there we'll see how we do
on time okay good so so really this
gives us a recipe for coming up with
these multi-group fairness Notions we're
focusing on calibration but really you
could imagine doing it for any notion
others have
um where you fix a group fairness notion
you then come up with some identifiable
collection and then you try to enforce
group fairness over every group defined
by this collection of subgroups okay
and again I'm I'm really
leaning on this interpretation of
Boolean functions as subgroups
okay good I'm going to push forward and
give you some definitions now so
um
the first simplest notion that we're
gonna think about is called
multi-accuracy
multi-accuracy or multi accuracy in
expectation is a weakened version of
multi-calibration where we're only going
to insist on unbiased predictions over
each uh
over each function in our class okay
really it's some sort of first order
condition if you will
um it what the notion says is that the
subpopulation functions should be
uncorrelated with your residuals with
the errors you're making okay
um so for for a collection of functions
multi-accuracy says that for every
function in the in the class this uh
approximate equality holds
okay that that my predictions
um
are are accurate in expectation over the
subpopulations defined by c
um with respect to law
average over C the expectation of Y and
the expectation of P tilde vets look the
same
good so I'll show you what
multicolibration is so so this is sort
of the simplest notion uh
multi-calibration takes it a step
further
requires that your predictions aren't
just accurate in expectation or aren't
just unbiased but really that they're
calibrated over these subpopulations
okay calibration again requires me to
condition on my predicted value
it says look at the level sets of my
predictor I want you to be uncorrelated
with sort of the errors that you're
making
um even conditioned on or uncorrelated
with subpopulations even conditioned on
the level six even within each level
and uh good so that that's sort of the
notion right so this multiplying by C of
X here again one can think about this as
conditioning on membership in some
subpopulation
yes Peter why do you not just include
the conditioning event
approximate conditioning events
[Music]
um
basically so to find some you know pull
this out and do an indicator here or
something yeah absolutely you could so
so sort of the the uh
formal most formal definition I'll put
up on the board right now is some
approximate version of multiple
calibrations
um that that there's a number of ways
that you can formalize sort of exactly
what it means to be approximately
calibrated pretty sure I can tell you
all about it
um and yeah go ahead so just to
regarding to this question
so so the the point is that that
conditioning On My Level sets depends on
my predictor
right so so somehow
um I can move this
this uh
into C I can move it into functions that
take both X and my current prediction
but now there's a circularity it's it's
totally fine you can work with this we
do work with it
um but but
um
foreign
thank you
good and so again like this is a
technical approximate definition
um we'll see that various different
approximations can be used and how they
come up
um but the way that I think you should
think of it as as Alpha as being some
small constant like one percent and
um your predictor is being supported on
roughly one over Alpha buckets okay one
over Alpha prediction intervals
could you just remind us what the second
expectation is over is that over the
algorithms bringing this no so this
expectation is O is just over
um
sort of the the values that you would
witness the level sets
so yeah
so alternatively I could so what I'm
trying to get away from is saying for
every B in in this continuous if it
observes so another way you could say
this is work with this definition and
say that it's for every B in that is
supported by your position has positive
probability and even you need to say
non-trivial positive problems so could
you handle it by
uh
putting okay instead of give conditional
also multiply by the characteristic
function
and say that's approximately zero for
every V yes exactly that's correct and
now so so multiplying by the indicators
is uh better than conditioning on you
know uh these low measure events
um but now then you have to think about
what your outfit is and what
approximation engineer kind of require
the point is that that sort of if you
give out predictions on very small uh if
you give out predictions with very small
probability I'm not going to be able to
reason about this
indeed so we somehow need either your
approximation Vector to drop
precipitously based on like how many
values you're giving them
divide by the support size or
um
yes
this is implied that the Boolean
function C of x equals one for all X is
always included here because I would
need that for the correlate for the like
uncorrelated yeah yeah so so it's a good
idea to always throw in say the constant
one function
to recover at very least calibration
overall evaluation yes
good so so
um
what I wanted to impress upon you is
sort of how we were we had this
situation before where we had the
ability with calibrated predictions to
give out some fixed prediction across
the entire group
um the the the uh at least informal
claim here is that if
we are able to identify this group if we
are able to identify a subgroup then
multi-calibrator predictions cannot
Overlook the variation here they cannot
look like this they must look at least
this group needs to move up
and then subsequently the other you know
the complement would need to move down
um so so what what a bit more formally
than this
um we can we can sort of formalize this
idea that that multi-calibration can't
Overlook
um variation okay so so this is
there's a number of different claims you
could write down I'm not going to prove
this but but sort of to get a sense of
it suppose that there's some
um
subpopulation aren't in our uh in our
collection that has you know non-trivial
probability let's say constant
probability and
the expectation in this group
uh the expected outcome
conditioned on membership in this group
is actually pretty high
or alternatively you could say is is
very low
then if P tilde is C Alpha
multi-calibrated then then the squared
error at least
of your predictions conditioned on
membership in this group needs to be
pretty small
okay that's to say if you're able to
identify structure in y given X here if
your class identifies any population
that correlates significantly with the
outcome
then you can't Overlook that variation
over all such sets that for which that's
the case
I don't mean this to be super technical
but hopefully intuitively it makes sense
of what I'm trying to say
does it make sense
foreign
class
a future sections of these seats I know
but but they see that you want some kind
of closure property whatever group you
are working with it extends
yeah maybe uh quickly we're going to end
up with very small groups or with uh you
know uh Sigma algebra or something
why it's a zero one variable or is it a
probability
third last line for your very wise minus
y p till book
it seems like that would be often fairly
large yeah but but so it's a great
question the point is I'm actually
getting close to the label not not
because
um I'm assuming that this expectation is
very large but yeah exactly this is sort
of um
we could have replaced this with peace
star
close to the true probabilities
okay so um
we can't I'm going to push a little bit
forward when should I stop this uh
turkey Okay so
yeah let's let's say that
um good so hopefully I've convinced you
that this is an interesting idea we can
debate exactly what it's good for or
when it's appropriate as a concrete
notion of fairness
um but uh the technical outstanding
question is is sort of propose that this
is a good definition it should be an
effective to Be an Effective definition
we need to be able to learn it to
achieve multi-calibration okay and so
next
um what I'm going to do is outline a
learning algorithm for achieving
multicoloration
the claim will be that this algorithm is
data efficient and only uses standard
tools from super best learning much in
the way that uh boosting does
okay so let me give uh sort of the
highest level overview of the algorithm
you can do that before our break and
then we'll probably get to the technical
details after so at the highest level
we're going to reduce the problem of
learning a multi-calibrated predictor to
Simply auditing for multi-calibration
okay this is sort of the the
auditability condition that I mentioned
earlier but so in the auditing problem
what are we given we're given data uh X
Y pairs
okay and we'll think about having a set
of predictions uh P tilde of X on on
these X's okay and the auditing question
just simply asks does p tilde satisfy C
Alpha multi-calibration
and the algorithm will be iterative and
and will just simply go as
first we asked the auditor
are my predictions multi-calibrated and
we start with trivial predictions likely
then the auditor will say no you're not
multi-calibrated here is a set on which
you're miscalibured
the auditor Witnesses you this C
okay
then you do some update you ask again
and again the auditor Witnesses you some
C Prime now on which you're
miscalibrated okay and the the Insight
here the the algorithmic step is to say
given a set on which I'm miscalibrated
how do I update my predictions to move
towards something Global to make some
sort of global progress so that after
not too many iterations we're guaranteed
that the auditor will return yes you are
multi-colored
good so um good I guess I have time to
to put the algorithm up on the board so
um this is the algorithm
uh as you you know at the highest level
it's uh quite simple so we're just gonna
initialize the predictor to any kind of
predictor
um you know one half is is good we'll do
it for everyone and then we're gonna
repeat uh a process where uh the first
in this uh sort of iteration we're going
to check the multi-calibration
constraints okay for all C we're going
to check
whether there exists some seat that um
violates the condition significantly
okay if there is then we're gonna
formulate some sort of update to our
current predictions based on uh our
current predictions based on the set
that we observed that we witnessed and
based on Alpha
okay and we're just going to repeat that
over and over again
until hopefully
we we hit some point at which we
terminate when all of the constraints
are okay
okay
at present you know it's a big hopefully
it's uh when should this stop
um good so
I'll probably jump forward
um
this is the more technical version of uh
exactly what I just said where
um we have to do some sort of
um technical rounding here to make sure
that um we can again this has to do with
the sort of approximate notion of
multi-calibration and making sure that
what we're observing we can sort of
justify statistically but what we're
looking for is some see
and some V
on which the violation of this
constraint is significant both in terms
of the density of the prediction and in
terms of the violation
okay and here we'll set it to be Alpha
squared we'll see why that uh
we'll see why that makes sense
um and then we're just going to do an
additive update
okay the additive update is going to add
in some copy of our circuit C uh some
copy of the subpopulation that we're
witnessing
as well as indicating which level set
you're part of right now
I'm rushing through this because I'll
I'll do it again after the break but
um
first off the claim is that if this
algorithm mcboost returns a predictor at
all then it's multi-calibrated
that much should be pretty clear from
the termination condition
mcboost only returns something if there
does not exist a c such that uh
this condition is violated therefore it
must be multi-calibrated here
um this is why we sort of need to round
our predictions to
um one over Alpha intervals and why we
take Alpha squared because we're going
to sort of say that this probability
imagine that we had Alpha squared
violation on one over Alpha
buckets then this sums up to at most
Alpha
so so that's what we're looking for
we're looking for a significant
violation on one of one over Alpha
buckets
um so and
I claim that that gives you that um
violation
um and so then really the question then
becomes when when does this uh algorithm
actually terminate
okay and that's uh I I think I'll pause
there we can go take a break and come
back for
uh to answer this punch line okay did
you have a question
without
for small business because
yeah we'll talk about it for now for now
I'm assuming that you happen
great see you in half an hour
[Applause]
we'll start we'll meet back here at 11
A.M and start for the second half of the
talk
absolutely